قالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه انها ثلاثه
شهداء سقطوا برصاص الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها
بلده جبع قضاء جنين وقال شهد عياننا
القوات الاسرائيليه الخاصه اطلقت النار
على مركبه كان يستقلها الفلسطينيون
الثلاثه وكانت قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه تسللت
الى داخل البلده وفتحت نيران اسلحتها على
الفلسطينيين
ومن رام الله معنا الان مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد ضعنا في سوره اخر
التفاصيل التي تكشفت
التفاصيل ووفقا لشهود العيان وكذلك للبيان
الصادر عن الناطق العسكري باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان قوات الاحتلال كانت قد رصدت
هذه السياره التي كان في داخلها ثلاثه
مقاومين من كتيبه جبع التابعه لسرايا
القدس الذراع العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي
وانها حاصرتها عندما دخلت الى البلده بعد
ان كان جيش الاحتلال قد نشر واحتل اسطح
بعض المنازل ونشر من عناصر قواته المعروفه
بالمستعربين الذين يتخفون بالزي المدني
ومن ثم هو يدعي في بيانها انه كان يريد
اعتقال هؤلاء الشبان او هذه الخليه التي
يقول بانها سبق لها ان اطلقت النيران على
احدى مستوطنات الاسرائيليه في المنطقه
ولكن الشبان الثلاثه من داخل السياره
اطلقوا النيران على قوته فقام بقصف
السياره وقتل الثلاثه في داخلها ثم اخرجهم
وقد نشر صورا
دعا بانها لاسلحه وذخائر واموال كانت
بحوزتهم في تلك المنطقه المواطنون وشهود
العيان يؤكدون بان قوات الاحتلال كما يبدو
نصبت كمينا لهم من خلال ان تسللت عناصرها
المتخفيه بالزي المدنيه المعروفه
والمستعربين واحتلت بعض الاسطح المباني
ومن ثم كانت هناك قوات عسكريه قوات مشتركه
حسب البيان العسكري من الجهاز الامن العام
الشباك ووحدات المعروفه باليمام مكافحه
الاراده الخاصه كوماندوز التابع للشرطه
والحرس الحدود وهذه قامت بقصف السياره
وقتل من تواجد في داخلها وهم ثلاثه من
مقاتليه الجهاد الاسلامي كتيبه
جبع وهم احمد فشافشه ونايف ملايشه وسفيان
فاخوري
وقتلتهم وسحبت جثامينهم الى خارج السياره
والقتها على الارض هذا حسب ما هو
حتى الساعه بسقوط هؤلاء الشهداء الثلاثه
وايضا الطفل وليد نصار والرابع عشره من
عمره وهو من جنين كان قد اصيب بجراح من
جراء نيران القوات الاحتلال في مخيم
الجنين امس الاول يرتفع عدد الشهداء
الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه هذا العام الى 78
شهيدا
الفلسطينيون بطبيعه الحال على كافه
المستويات يرون بان قوات الاحتلال هناك
حاله من الاغال بالدم الفلسطيني وهي تواصل
عمليات القتل اوزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
في بيان قالت بان هذا سما هذا جراء ما
وصفته بالفشل الدولي او فشل المواقف
الدوليه التي الغير قادره على توفير
الحمايه للشعب الفلسطيني وحملت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه كامل المسؤوليه عن
هذه
عما جرى اليوم من قتل واغتيال في بلده جبع
الواقعه الجنوبيه مدينه جنين وقد صعد ذلك
من حاله التوتر والغضب والغليان في الشارع
الفلسطيني من جديد امس الاول ودع
الفلسطينيه سته شهداء في جنين واليوم
يودعون اربعه ثلاثه في جبع وطفل في جنين
متاثرا بجراحه وواضح بان قوات الاحتلال
ماضيه في عملياتها وحملاتها العسكريه في
قلب البلدات والمدن الفلسطينيه وتحديدا في
شمالي الضفه الغربيه منطقه جنين او محافظه
جنين لها من عدد الشهداء 31 شهيدا حتى
الان تليها في ذلك منطقه نابلس 18 شهيدا
وحسب ما يراه المراقبون فانك حكومه اقصى
اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل صعدت من عمليات
سفك دماء الفلسطينيين بشكل يشار الى ان
هناك شهيدا واحدا يوميا على الاقل اشكرك
مدير مكتب الجزيره من رام الله وليد
العمري شكرا